[Applause]
next up is is Logan Graham from Oxford
and it's gonna be about Labor analysis
and yeah thank you thank you also for
putting on this workshop it's a really
really phenomenal idea and very much
needed this is joint work with my
co-author Paul Duckworth who's sitting
over there if you raise your hand and
Mike Osborne who is maybe live tweeting
on Twitter
there will be no fewer than six quizzes
so make sure you pay attention so this
comes from my personal background
passion from previous research in
economics I'm doing my PhD in machine
learning at the moment and what better
way than to combine the two it's a topic
that's very close to us in that the
world is becoming increasingly automated
or at least people say that work across
industries and job types is said to be
automatable the problem is we're still
as yet unclear about what is automatable
we don't really know why automation
happens in the first place and in
particular intelligent technology the
things that we produce and the things
that we research is a unique and new
phenomenon that we believe will affect
this disproportionately relative to
previous advancements so how do we get
more clarity on this we've been trying
to predict or understand what the future
of work will look like for quite a long
time and this is a broad thrust of the
movements from the 80's 90's and 2000's
we have we developed broad tasks and job
frameworks trying to say what is a type
of task or what is a type of job and how
does that relate to our ability to
technologized or automate it
my supervisor Mike then produced a
relatively incendiary and interesting
paper in 2013 which said let's see
instead of trying to hypothesize from
broad frameworks down let's go from the
data up and see what patterns it tells
us and they brought together a new data
set that labeled occupations directly
and then tried to predict for
occupations that weren't labeled and
then we're very recently and where this
work fits in the we're showing fits in
the new thrust which is the attempt to
model tasks directly the belief is
occupations and thing
about what occupations are gonna be
automated is just much too coarse of a
framework to give us a good handle of
what we should do about it
so instead what we wanted to do with
this work was go and ask the experts
directly and in fact I see a few faces
in the room who actually answered the
survey and to help us collect the data
set that we'll be exploring in this talk
so here's the broad thrust of what we
wanted to do we wanted to combine all
these movements so far and what we did
was we collected a survey of 156 experts
which provided us 400 or 4500 Plus
ratings these are individual task
ratings from the US Department of
Labor's own net database which is an
extremely helpful and sort of
state-of-the-art so far
database about work this gave us we then
aggregate tasks into will we append to
tasks the feature vectors which is a
hundred and twenty dimensional numeric
vector that describes the occupation
that that task is under and this
dimensional this 120 dimensional vector
describes the skills the knowledge and
the ability is required to perform the
occupation we aggregate the tasks into
their what are called work activity
groups we get some variation in these
feature vectors and for each of these
three hundred-plus we the final numbers
314 activity labels we now have an
aggregated feature vector which means we
can build a supervised machine learning
model for this we compared a lot of
different models and found that using
the gaussian process with specifically
an RBF kernel as well as an ordinal
likelihood to represent the ordinal
nature of the labels which were as
you'll see labeled as one two three and
four to represent an ordinal spectrum
between not-at-all automatable and
entirely automatable and if you answer
this survey you will know that that was
that was the case and also the advantage
of the gaussian process here is to allow
us some sort of uncertainty as well to
reflect the subjective nature of this
data set and then what we can do from
there because it's really difficult to
take you know all of you in this room
and get you to rate every single piece
of work that is being performed to your
based on your expertise we can now build
a model that maps from the patterns of
automate ability as well as the feature
vectors that describe the work that is
automatable in order to predict for the
remaining 1753 work activities that are
just very timely and costly too to try
and collect data on and so given that
this is what we've done so far I'll show
you what the results are from well the
preliminary results from the survey are
however a first disclaimer if there are
any journalists in the room I think one
of the sort of worst aspects of the
community discussing automation is how
incendiary and and and prone it is to
hot takes and should be a disclaimer
that this is preliminary results and
nothing that we say here is going to
conclusively tells you whether or not
Terminator will or we're not happen etc
so what did you say so an interesting
first pattern instead of listing the
individual tasks which we will be
releasing as I'll mention in an open
source database and we have some more
information on our poster over there
just to give you a broad thrust of what
the results are the first is when we
aggregate tasks into their activity
groups broad level groups that cut
across occupations is an industry that
describe what sort of work they do we
find it's fairly normally distributed
and some of the results are fairly
expected so you'll see there that
administration and physical and manual
work activities are among the most
automatable where a label of three
represents mostly automatable a label of
two represents mostly not automatable
label of one is entirely not and label
of four is is entirely so well on the
other hand tasks that required complex
cognitive reasoning and decision-making
coordinating developing managing and
advising things that require creativity
unspecified metrics of performance human
interaction these are things I think as
you will know are expectedly less likely
to be automated
however a very interesting trend occurs
that despite being normally relatively
distributed across work types they're
not so across occupation types that is
automatable work it tends to be
concentrated together within different
types of occupations and so in
particular we see some very evident
trends here sales office and production
as you'll see here in yellow red and and
light orange are among the most
automatable of the occupation activities
something that was surprising to me as
well the discussion about automation is
often about manual work and indeed that
tends to be the case within the
economics literature since the 70s as a
very key characterization of how our
economy has progressed showing that
tasks like sales and related occupations
is quite a new one because that involves
a face of human interaction and in the
expanded paper that we are going to be
publishing at AI yes and in some of the
ongoing results we speculate a little
bit about why that might be and dive
into some of the details of why that
potentially why that occurs while on the
other hand again complex cognitive tasks
the people who are the managers the
lawyers the the scientists the educators
people requiring great degrees of
empathy and human interaction and
adjustability are much less likely to be
automated or automatable so two quizzes
stick up your hand on the left side with
one finger on the right side with two
fingers if you believe this is the
answer
so which activity is more automatable
choreographing dances or storing records
and related materials phenomenal is
anybody saying one okay good your your
very much right storing records has
almost entirely automated well
choreographing dances very much not so
here's a potentially triggering one
tricky one conferring with customers and
designers to determine order
specifications or teaching online
courses who believes it's conferring
with customers is more automatable
teaching online courses good it's a
little split
indeed we see quite a stark difference
here conferring with customers as you
see it in the O net database breaks down
into some relatively routinize Abul and
an intelligence driveable processes
lastly positioning construction forms or
molds or directing material handling and
moving activities split again the answer
here is they're actually quite close but
marginally more so for actually
directing the activities rather than
positioning things all right so we also
studied what features are most likely to
increase autom automated bility or
associated with an increase in automate
ability clerical skill or social
perceptiveness everybody's saying
generally one and indeed clerical skill
is one of the most automated bility
increasing features that we have social
perceptiveness is automate ability
decreasing mathematics or science
interesting extremely split again quite
significantly mathematics because these
encompass tasks that are relatively
clerical as well numerical calculated I
don't know if anybody does back drop by
hand anymore if you do let's say you
were very automatable negotiation versus
sales and marketing mostly sales and
marketing some negotiation and indeed I
kind of gave away the answer prior
interestingly we also see trends across
the income in education the humble and
hardworking Henrietta's who are
relatively lower income though despite
still doing very well but also are less
likely to have a bachelor's degree at
least to perform the job or you see
massive clusters each point is is
proportional to the occupations
employment whereas the educated earner
Effie's are relatively robust but you
can see that there's a lot less work
being performed within these green boxes
which means that it disproportionately
trend of automate ability disparate is
disproportionately affects the least
adjustable now I don't have much time
but we found some interesting
disparities between what our experts
were saying and what our model was
saying
and we actually have a full table of it
in the paper so I encourage you to check
out the website but on the right hand
you see expert labels felt that
measuring equipment outcomes relatively
automatable or equipment outputs whereas
our model thought that was less
automated now just to conclude because
we'll be because we'll be open sourcing
this this data set this is an initial
approach we would like people to go and
answer some of the questions that we
think are very important now that we
have granular task level data some are
real world validation do does our model
predict what actually is automatable in
the world what is the difference between
being automatable and actually going
forth and being automated how much
economic value is either stored in
potential untapped automate ability and
what are the characteristics across
employees trends of Technology
demographics etc we'd also encouraged
for the research to collect novel data
sets etc and we propose a call to arms
as a launching point for automate
ability researchers we would like more
experts and more data on this trend and
in particular in terms of collecting
this data we think having better high
dimensional task descriptions is a very
good thing and we are seeing some work
just about to be published such the
initial results from others starting to
do exactly this and lastly better and
more precise definitions of automate
ability so that we can actually identify
and explain the causal effect here the
last the result of having this better
data is going to be a few fold right now
I think we live in a world of fear
uncertainty and doubt about the future
of work whether or not it's us who are
we'll you know statistically our highly
paid and highly educated or it's not us
and having better data will allow us to
set better policy change ourselves as
workers change the businesses that we
might run or look at new growth
enhancing opportunities so we can
replace this with a sort of optimism
clarity and confidence thank you
great thanks a lot Logan's fascinating
talk so I leave a question repeated mmm
yes so the question is how if I'm you
know as I understand it how we measure
the difference or is it worth measuring
the difference between whether or not
something is automatable and whether or
not we actually want to automate it for
some sort of social perceived goodness
etc and there's other dimensions to it
as well as you know something might be
very automatable you just might not make
money automating it so it's a business
owner there may not even be an incentive
so technically capable may be socially
or economically not desirable what we
wanted to do was just figure out what is
technically possible and we hope that
you know further research can be done on
on exactly this because this is is
really what matters that we know what
can be done in the transaction selling
is a very human thing I mean good I mean
I wouldn't mind if there were less but I
suspect that when the value of the good
is going to be large it'll be worth it -
I mean for companies to continue having
humans doing it mm-hmm is that well this
is an interesting point just by a show
of hands over the past three years who
has shifted a large amount of their
purchases online to something like
Amazon I certainly have how many of you
wish there was a human in the loop when
you clicked the purchase button on your
Amazon Prime order of a the friends
season one through six companies selling
wishes yeah yeah this is this is this is
really important being able to
distinguish between what will and and
won't be automatable for very various
characteristics of the product is really
really important just as a quick side
note one analysis I didn't show up here
it's something that I hope to spend more
time on which is what happens when we
take tasks or activities that feature
very very highly like top 3% in a
particular feature with something like
negotiation and we found different types
of tasks that varied in terms automate
ability so some activities that were for
example very human facing like a very
open-ended sales process where the
customer doesn't know what they want
versus the one where they do know where
they want then it's just a search
problem yeah right so one follow-up
question who knows what you just showed
because I have the feeling that it's
pretty uneven it's an uneven
distribution around the world right so
there are some industrial societies that
are always very advanced that don't pay
attention to AI as much as they can have
the u.s. or China right yeah and this is
probably going to be news for them if
they ever see it and this could be you
know who create I don't know how to call
attention or like problems because the
investment that you see here in AI is
not what I see Europe for example right
and I guess the stakes are high this
particular situation yeah so you're
asking about the geographic distribution
effects of automation yes this is a
really really big important topic Mike
and his associate research has some
stuff extending his previous research
trying to say how do we take that
dataset and extend it to countries and I
believe they were looking at East Africa
what does that mean for their economy
and China in particular it's a good
question I think your your first point
about who knows about it maybe what we
owe as a duty is to make sure everybody
can have the best automate ability
information no matter where you are in
the world
I think they'll be all we have the
questions let's thank the speaker yeah
and we can continue talking um through
the poster session yeah thank look
absolutely thank you sorry